I'm 67 66
I'm 72 swam with snakes at Argentina
whitewater rafting I'm not gonna say Oh
too extreme
my name is Phil booth I developed tandem
jumping in the early 1980s there is not
now nor will there ever be a perfect
perfect airplane or pilot or for that
matter a perfect student I don't see any
gravestone I'm gonna get you all ready
right now who wants to be the first -
why not I though most of my friends said
they're not really gonna make you go
skydiving are they checking it's
hilarious I'm so grateful for the
opportunity you got to get out there and
enjoy life what's life if you don't live
it let me feel that jump I want to jump
suit I think they are adorable looking I
think I'll go on natural angels fly
because they take themselves lightly
don't take life too seriously
I love that one I used to say that all
the time I'd forgotten it
they open the door for that first time
and you actually see how far you are
away from the earth that's where it
really begins to sink in what you're
doing
they say there's peak life experiences
well this was one of them
you can't grab enough of the scenery in
your mind's eye its total faith knowing
that everything's going to be fine
I felt no fear I felt no fear of the
ground below and me not attached to it
the transition to the parachute opening
is almost like going through a different
dimension
it was so peaceful
was like some kind of euphoric sort of
nirvana
you see the ground coming up you know
it's it's all gonna be over in a few
seconds and it was just amazing you can
let go the harness now I feel like I
aged 10 years how does my hair look nan
air is so loud like a freight train I'm
still not hearing very well I hear
echoes in my head but that will go away
it's not a matter feeling younger it's
just being more confident being in more
control I don't feel old anyway I just
succeeded I think one of my own limit I
feel very proud of myself
regret would be not to do it it was
wonderful I never want to do it again I
would do it again if I had the
opportunity I've always taken that leap
of faith and it's always paid off
you